okay for people joining this live stream
we are talking about the compiler and
its feedback to users about where it has
found errors
so Tom took it away yes fine okay so the
idea is to provide markup showing where
the error is in the input
so it's it's possible to generate the
compiler can generate a version of the
input which shows where the error arose
and
now now what we can't do is track this
to the actual Source
um and then when we talked about this
before you talked about a compilation
error actions option that would control
what to do with this so that seems like
what we only the default would be now I
don't know if we need to go through with
this but these are the sorts of things
that can be done so here's a you know
I'm doing a function compile and I'm
applying sine to something that's a
Boolean and there isn't a sign of
Boolean and so that's an error and so I
can generate this um
you know it wraps a compilation error
around this so obviously that would be
marked up
um specially now some slight we have to
think about
um when there are function declarations
the first thing you're showing is that
at a pure symbolic level
the thing returns
when you say that funk equals function
compile blah blah blah it is returning
on its output line it is returning
something which has wrapping around the
error position is that correct
it's return yes that's that's more or
less right yes it's returning a failure
object and in that failure object is
information telling it where's the
failure object I don't understand your
output right I put a semicolon on there
I mean so let's see it right fine well
I'll run this I have to run this in a
different branch
um
you want to actually see this running or
you want to see the video there's
um it's in my there's one already in the
ux yeah yeah fine right oh right yes
well no no it well there's another exact
example yeah so
right eventually right so here's the
failure object here right okay so what's
the relationship of that to the out line
after the FFX well somewhere down in
here there's a source thing here and the
source thing here contains the
information about where it lives in the
original expression
okay not not using the modern code tree
AST stuff some other method I've known
where it is possibly no no it there
isn't enough information there no
because this is right okay okay okay
so and this is just showing different
sorts of Errors it can track I mean
these will have to work through now some
tricky issues you know when there are
functions I'm just I'm I'm I'm drowning
here I don't understand what the overall
point is so the overall point is what
you're doing is you're having symbolic
wrapping of the initial of the input in
which you'll repeat your returning the
input as part of the failure object with
wrapping that indicates
fine no why don't it's probably more
useful if Noah shows his stuff because
that I think that would be more more
helpful to you actually
Noah why don't you sure yeah so um you
can see that right yes right okay so
yeah I mean Tom just described the the
premise of what we're doing
um and so the idea is that you know we
want to add a control to be able to show
you know essentially some some marked up
inputs a marked up copy of the input
um and so you know the sensical place to
put this really is on the end of the
message
um because the message is always going
to be thrown in this case of course as
we saw with props on Tom screen the uh
you know this failure object and that
seems a natural place to put this you
may not see it so it you know it really
has to be the message and so I'm putting
this little sort of source button here
on the end of you know a compile error
message
um
so okay so this is kind of like I guess
the simplest example you know you click
this button
um and then this this message you know
just kind of expands open and you see
um essentially what you know Tom was
showing but instead of it being wrapped
with compilation error or whatever it
was it's now just you know underlighted
and sort of highlighted here so however
long that input was if that was a 20
line input the 20 line input was
repeated underneath the message is that
correct
so yes but we can do things like you
know clip it with a pane so that it
doesn't take up
you know or like a whole screen of
notebook
um
sorry and that's going to make another
point which I've just forgotten um but
yes we can we can clip it and I've got
an example of that
yeah yeah so you know this is like a
really long
you know section of code and you know
it's it sort of clipped it and scrolled
to the bit smarter
so one question and maybe this is
exactly what the breadcrumb example is
that you're going to show later is
um I mean there might be cases where you
really need the whole stack Trace
because it's you know the bottom
function call that failed is you know oh
you can't you know it'll be something
really random but but but you know you
need to look higher up in the stacks
yeah that's exactly what the breadcrumb
is yes okay perfect yeah
um just before I move on from this
section
um I'll just make the point that you
know there are some sort of conceptual
similarities to you know to Brenton's
code analysis pods but this is distinct
and so that's why it kind of looks
similar but it is intentionally designed
differently so that it's sort of you
know you're not going to get the too
confused hopefully
um but yeah so you know then we've got
like sorry so one one other quick sorry
I didn't interject but one other quick
thing would be
um is there anything that's that's
compiler specific about this in the
sense that I know there's been talk
about having sort of better uh stack
traces with with all messages at various
points I wonder if maybe this design
would also be relevant for that
so that's kind of an aside
can I say one thing there this is not a
runtime analysis this is a compiled time
analysis so that's yeah sure sure but
there's similar things that you might
think that's correct time stuff yes
so so one so yes you're right and what
one difference is that here because
these errors are fatal right it's that's
why I've kind of been able to just head
this
um kind of provenance pod with the with
the message and then therefore you're
kind of looking at just like that you
know the the the the path the source of
that one message with you know if you if
you if you've got an input if you've
evaluated an input and then a bunch of
message you know there's a message
message spew
um then you you might want to sort of
pick a copy of the input with you know
several kind of message sources marked
up
um and then in that case it makes sense
to do more like what we're doing you
know in uh
in code analysis
where it's a little more structured you
you can list things out at the bottom
um and there's no reason why you can't
Mark everything at once right so you
could have both message provenance and
code analysis in this um and you just
list them all out you know underneath
um and so yes there are similarities but
I still think it's you know this is kind
of it's a slightly different problem
that that is asking for a slightly
different ux right okay okay well but
actually for some other context though
for the error handling uh they're
handling working group stuff
um I mean one of the ideas is to have
you know there's going to be some like
what I don't remember exactly with the
designs but there's gonna be some like
raise function which produces a failure
object that is sort of a definitive you
know usually fatal error that will
usually go all the way to the top and
the plan is for that to include some
some kind of nice stack trace of some
kind so this might be more relevant for
for that case but but yeah
well I need to I mean yeah I should I
should I should um get myself caught up
on that then because yes it sounds like
that's the ux could be similar in both
cases if not the same okay nothing else
I'm going to send this this screenshot
to that group so yeah
um okay so so the basic Point here is
a compile time error is generated
this source button is a way of showing
it's kind of an enhanced error message
now I suspect there are other error
messages elsewhere in the system
which would also benefit from the
possibility of a kind of enhanced
information about the error type
you know uh
you know opener below the message so to
speak I mean in other words for millions
of years messages have been pure text
we're now going out of the pure text
you know domain to this possibility of
having an additional tray or whatever
you call it underneath
the actual message and I I just messages
have a more info on the left I mean
that's there's stuff there that's pretty
limited it's limited but I mean the
point that we're making here and this
could be accessed from something on the
left as well the point we're making here
is that there's another place where you
can put information about an enhanced
enhanced confirmation about a message
in this tray mechanism that's what
that's what Noah is proposing here
basically that there is a I don't know
this could be generalized yeah yeah
so in other words I mean just just you
know brainstorming for a second about
other messages
that I mean anybody think of any other
messages that would benefit from such a
tray
so just presumably it's not necessarily
you're saying that kind of anything that
might go in that trade not just the
Departments that's what I'm saying I'm
saying that there could be yes but I
mean this is
what are we saying did the defining
feature is just that it has highlighted
code in it
probably I mean yes why why aren't we
putting
you know any message has provenance
right which is visible in the stack
trace on the left to some extent but
this is an alternative provenance
mechanism
why wouldn't this be something that any
message could benefit from
sure
well yeah but I think there often isn't
useful highlighted code as you see if
you ever look at it there might be other
things on the left if you had if you
were loading a file and you've got a
syntax error you could have a thing to
open the file
sure yeah that could be nice that might
be useful
but I mean yeah it may make more sense
to First just consider this in the
context of the compiler where it's
fairly well defined and then exactly
generalize it but fair enough
okay at least we have all the codes
there and it's not part of the kernel or
something like okay it's just part of
the kernel then you can't introspect it
again it's only really for top level
code
no I understand but there was always
some in the stack Trace there is always
some head that generated the message you
could always show the code highlighting
that head so to speak or that
sub-expression right
I mean there's there's a there's a
function there's a function that should
exist you know maybe in a function
repository or something it's like a you
know pretty stacked trace or something
where it basically just takes you know
this sort of extended output of Stack
but then produces some fancy thing like
this which I think you can make a basic
version of with just the information
from stack and that would show you know
right that would basically show in a way
where you as a human can actually
navigate it
yes well why not I mean that seems like
a good thing for somebody to judge build
that will be the direct analog of this
but okay for the compiler there's code
there's highlighting of which part of
the code had the error which we could
generalize
and what else to say about this so this
case where it's tiny it's all rather
straightforward but now
um you're going to show more stuff with
bigger cases down below sure and where
you've got sort of you know functions
are actually referencing other functions
um and so uh yeah I mean in in in you
know if you open the pod in this case
you've now got like a breadcrumb trail
and so it's it's kind of in reverse
order like your inbox a bit I guess
um where the the kind of the root source
is open by default and at the top
um and then you know the next kind of
place where that function was called is
underneath it
um I I don't know if this is I I'm
almost certain this would require C plus
plus support so I don't know how soon we
could have such a thing but
um having a link to like if if what have
I said uh link to the cell containing
its function if the cell still exists uh
and you know maybe includes
communication if it sells me now it's
you know some way of kind of you know
clicking that and then going to uh if
that's the right thing yes it is
number one is
it's explicitly visible
you could wait a minute
I in this particular case it's giving
you
compilation if they don't markup ux dot
NB what does that mean that that that's
that's the snow yeah it's an yes so I
should have pointed that out
um and it just happens that that you
know both of these are in the same file
and maybe yes maybe this could say
something a little more intelligent um
uh I guess maybe let me just jump ahead
a second to you know this is where so
this is where the breadcrumb trail is
going through multiple piles right and
so now you know this is compiler file
one.wl line you know X and you've got
all of these and then of course the
thing at the very bottom would be this
notebook
um maybe that's a slightly clearer you
know version of this I understand
um I'm sorry I'm totally confused
there's a message the message comes from
a single piece of code somewhere
right correct so why does it have a big
stack of provenance here isn't it
this message was generated from an error
in this particular
um
well to two problems I think that's not
okay two problems with that one I think
there might be cases where that's not
entirely true because it has to do with
some sort of type thing where it's
solving and it couldn't find a solution
and there are multiple conflicting
things that maybe you know scattered
about in a somewhat complicated way but
I'm not even sure that's the real the
real reason I think it's like this is
just that you often need the the trace
because the base error is something you
know something stupid like if you ever
look at a real stack Trace like you know
if you you know the kernel crashes and
you look at the stack Trace it'll be
like the actual thing that crashes is
like in eval and it'll be some random oh
it access to pointer that was null or
something like that that's not where the
real error is yeah so yeah you need to
step up one or two frames in the stack
to find what what calling uh I don't
know wrong but do you have enough
information in the compiler to go up
that I'm confused how does it know
it knows what function it's compiling it
has the chain of functions you know in
the chain of functions it has that
information and if it was loaded from a
file it knows what file it's loaded from
it doesn't know what at the moment
doesn't know what line is coming from
okay right so
okay so in that top case
when it is the current file it really
should say current file it shouldn't
give the name of the file it's too weird
to give the name of the file
yeah I agree yeah
it doesn't totally know that it's the
current file actually the current
notebook doesn't really know that
really well knows the name of the
notebook and he knows the name of the
current notebook so it can probably how
did you know you didn't you know you
didn't have a definition written in a
different notebook
that happened to be called the same
thing and with the same file no no I I
put that funk equals function in a
different notebook and then I run
function compile in this notebook sure
sure but then it would say that other
notebook name but then for the line and
from this notebook but it doesn't know
that it came from another notebook
why not if it knows what notebook it
came from and it knows the name of the
car it doesn't I I oh this is a
different problem okay this isn't a
problem with the you know this is a
technical problem with knowing what
notebook came from yeah oh so it's kind
of the same as my skepticism about
whether we can actually put the cell
here so it's even more fundamental than
that we don't even know what notebook it
came from
well
I mean then Noah's annotation there is
irrelevant anyway so we're just giving
the people that's right
actually I don't think that's true
because the point is that you can you
can still get you know you you lose the
formatting and stuff but you can still
get the actual expression so you can
still do an annotation like that but it
won't have the formatting even if you
don't know where it came from
sure
that's all true yeah yeah it has to be
formatted in in the in the thing yeah
right but I mean so but but what we're
saying is you can't annotate it with
that file information no because right
so is that true of these as well then no
it no it no when it's loaded from a file
it knows what file it's come from oh
okay yeah yeah I I've said that yeah so
yes sorry yeah I've misunderstood
um uh okay so I need to think of
something else to kind of label these
with okay the final thing
if anything
yeah you need you need some heading
because I mean there are there are some
other annotations it could put like like
these functions have names in in the
type environment it could have that they
have types it could have that I mean
there are some things that it could put
that that might be useful let me just
zoom out what we're achieving here okay
the main point is that is is simply to
be able to show I mean ultimately we'd
like to be able to click and see the
source code that see in order to know
where to edit the source code
um that might be problematic so to speak
correct but this is a second best to
that of just being able to see the
annotated code that has a problem
I think this would be useful I don't
know Mark what do you do you think this
would be useful yeah if you had the
tight markup of the calling function too
and then you had the type there of the
function types integer 64 so it was a
floating point being called in Floats or
something like that then you'd
immediately see oh it's a tight mismatch
or something like that and uh yeah and
that would be uh like okay Stephen wants
it done
like to actually suggest something at
least here you have a visual indication
well that's a good start but so yeah so
it's a starting point to get into the
point with the Stephen one so um what
you're saying Mark is just have more
information I mean what nowhere is
providing yeah yeah it's purely the code
that was problematic highlighted with a
specific piece of that code yeah I I I
add a little bit of extra like the
calling function has the type signature
or something of the calling function too
or or
Noah has to invent ux to represent that
that's the point here yeah okay I don't
know how hard it is but no it's just
it's a question
we have meetings like this
the whole point is that if you define
the information like what Noah has here
is he's showing the file that the thing
is coming from yeah saying this you want
to see the function it's coming from
um which is a different thing so
and the type signature too because then
you can match it with the type signature
of the call and that would be uh sort of
an additional thing that you could
probably catch
but um
I mean you could have additional
information even collapse it down and
you could click on it to open it up and
you know it could be layered I don't
know exactly how it should be structured
however but but certainly yeah we can
add to this uh okay but so let's just
figure out what we need to figure out
for this meeting
um
so you know Noah was presenting this ux
what is this the primary thing that we
have to deal with in this meeting this
this is the primary thing in this
meeting there's a couple of other things
we discussed last week
um or maybe it was the week before about
um you know a typed hint and an if
compiled
um but uh this this is the main thing so
okay well I mean looks to me like if
this is implementable then it sounds to
me like there's a some additional
tagging that's needed which is the name
of the function that thing is in
I mean I don't understand does the
function always have a name
I mean in a function declaration it has
a name but in a there's an anonymous no
it could be a Lambda function it doesn't
always have a name you're you're correct
okay
well so we just need okay so okay what
else do we need to figure out here
well just does this seem sensible you
know is this a reasonable Direction
Let's
the word Source seems okay
uh the way the tray opens up seems okay
I mean it's a little bit visually the
fact that it's so that
um the message isn't comparatively small
type and I think you go down a font size
or something perhaps in the um uh in the
code that you have inside this box well
I think it's nice if it's the same size
as the code outside of it
possibly so but but maybe a a similar
thing would be um and maybe this already
exists but it'll be nice if you pick you
know have some corner or something that
you can drag and make the uh the pain
bigger
just you know if you have a giant piece
of code
yes
okay and meanwhile
the highlighting color
um I mean is that red under whatever is
that real or is that what what do you
imagine is the full annotation that you
are giving to the incorrect code
uh as in
so sorry I don't understand the question
as in that's what's on but yeah I'm
asking you would be marked up with like
two things background right you've got a
squiggly and you've got a pink
background which is the thing that you
so is that what you are proposing is the
way of indicating the Eric area oh I see
yeah yeah which is like uh which is how
we do it currently in code analysis okay
fine fine I I don't like squigglers
because sometimes they hide things at
the bottom you can't see what letter it
is or something squigglers
pure pink
purific is not going to be strong enough
but red or could there be like a well
maybe maybe that's a bug with squigglies
and they should be placed a little bit
lower or something like that yeah I
think we use them in lots of places so
if yeah it's actually unreadable that's
kind of a bug yeah so let's solve that
I think the squiggly is the right thing
okay so can we move on here so then
you've got this this kind of these two
mechanisms you've got this iframe like
mechanism where it's a scrollable thing
you've got this the specification where
it's from with the opener now you have
this one additional thing where you
probably want to say line blah blah Dash
and then the name of the function if
there is a function name there
control
does that make sense
yeah yeah yeah
um and and so in in in the case where
it's coming from in the case where it's
not being called from a while is there
something useful like
is there something that we'd always have
that would be suspensable to use as the
label well do we know where it's coming
from in terms of of Dom pointers or
whatever or what
do we know anything about where it came
from we don't know anything about it so
it's just a unidentified flying piece of
code that we reconstituted and printed
here is that correct that's exactly
correct okay
well then I think we put okay well if
there's some things are immediately
sensible to to put here then I can think
of like an icon or something yeah
um yeah cool okay why do you need it why
isn't it just scroll up why isn't it
just the same as you had in the case
where you had a pure well it may be
large and it needs to be collapsed to
begin with right so
um
if it's large why isn't it that iframing
thing
it would be but it would be but the
point being is that it needs to be
collapsible and then when you collapse
it what's it gonna say like it needs a
lit like the opener it needs well I
suppose we could not have a a label on
the open but it feels like there should
be something there yeah no imagine you
have ten openers and they're all
unlabeled it's kind of like why is there
like so why is there an opener at all
well
had the code right there
well it's not unwieldy so because I mean
you know if all of these were opened by
default no no that's hopeless that's
hopeless but I'm saying if only if one
of them is open if there's only one okay
in the case of unidentified flying code
there is only one thing is that not
correct that is not correct
okay because there might have you might
have one piece of code from The Notebook
but then that piece of code then calls
something from your package which then
has also which is stuff which is the
example here right because the thing
right the thing furthest away from the
source was you know something called in
this notebook
and that'll basically always be the case
that there's something in your notebook
that failed and then there's a bunch of
stuff in the package that failed if
you're ever doing something with a
package
so you need a mechanism
oh God unknown please speak verbally if
you have something to say
okay well I didn't want to interrupt the
flow of the conversation but like if you
have a lot of code and there's like a
function compile somewhere in the middle
of your code then that message will can
appear you know many pages down in your
notebook so it might be nice to be able
to
you know get that side by side right
like in the sense that you I guess you
can copy out the cell but if there's a
button it basically says okay pop this
out into a palette or an another
notebook
then it's a little bit easier to to fix
your code without having to scroll up
and down up and down up and down all the
time
actually that was uh that was on the
to-do list ages ago for lint pods and I
think it was just forgotten about so yes
I absolutely agree and it should be done
copy this Noah can you copy probably
another notebook you can't can you
yeah
um well can you copy it can you uh if I
select that outer bracket copy and make
a new notebook and paste this this
thing's gone hasn't it
you mean the interface
yes yes oh yeah because it shouldn't
serialize which I think is correct
um and so you know although and I think
that's what I've written at the bottom
uh or yeah although these provenance
pods have been shown with kind of you
know this message style cell bracket
I think they're actually going to have
to be implemented as attached cells
inline attached cells somehow okay
the message at the top will serialize
it's just direct provenance pod will not
yeah I mean yes it's a little bit
inconvenient because I might want to
copy that into a notebook and have it
side by side and then search up and down
for well that's what I know they're
saying so you know that would be a
breakout thing where the thing breaks
out into a palette of some kind
the message may just be like you know 15
pages down the notebook and then you
have to scroll up and down to kind of
see what you did wrong I mean that
right that's the problem
why exactly go ahead oh okay I was going
to say Tom's rice in the sense that like
okay this this attached piece will
disappear because it's just an inline
cell but you know once you've copied
this message into a new notebook to the
side you can just click on the source
button again and open okay okay
but uh but but I mean why not have it
pop out put it into a palette that seems
perfectly sensible
yeah I like that because then then you
can use it you know side by side or
something all right so the one thing we
have to figure out here is what does it
say when it's unidentified flying code
what is the analog of and is it always
at the top the is is it always the first
entry that's the unidentified code
the last one
no it's the other way around so the way
around isn't it
no because this is at the top this is
like sort of organized the way an inbox
be organized right so the the thing
that's kind of closest to actually the
source of the message is at the top yeah
identified codes at the bottom
yes well but it's not always because for
example you could have something where
you know I mean always you'll have some
unidentified code at the bottom if
you're calling it from a notebook but
then uh but then maybe you know you fed
some Lambda function or you've had some
function name to you know this giant
package that you define that function in
a notebook and so you know both the top
and the bottom will be unidentified okay
fine so then then there needs to be some
way of indicating two things the uh
okay so that could be it could be
is it the the two types of information
where did it come from file wise and
what is the name of the function that it
came from
when do those when are those available
do you understand what I'm asking so
sorry so you want to know the file so
sorry I was thinking about no I'm saying
there are two pieces of information that
are potentially displayable on noaa's
annotation lines right one is the file
name and the other is the function name
correct and and maybe the function type
as well yeah
okay all right fine so the function name
if it has one is always available and
the function type
if one was given is always available and
the function they're all three of these
things are you might have it or you
might not
is that right dependence on which one
you have that if you have one then you
have to have another type thing no not
no I could make something all right so
so we just need to so Noah just needs a
a ux and design for those three pieces
of information available as annotations
at every every place here make sense yes
yes
okay okay anything anything else we need
to figure out here yeah okay I have a
question over here so do do I know where
the compiler file to dial you L is so
which directory it is
that presumably is what that Arrow but
that opens the right it would be
reasonable to have a mouse over that
says what the what the um yeah yeah
sorry the the question was is it
possible to see the entire directory of
this file Yeah question is to have a
mouse over yeah yeah
yeah sure yeah okay
yeah and then clicking that obviously
yeah
okay and so the the other piece of this
is the pop out of this thing as a
palette so that you can see it
independent of uh its location so to
speak so that you can scroll up and down
in your in your notebook and still have
on screen the information on what the
error was
yes and you know we we've done we we've
got ux mechanisms none of which have
been implemented but you know we've
designed for solving you know this
similar problem in both the notebook
toolbar and previously in code analysis
so I'll just look back at those and
figure out something that will work here
okay
all right
cool all right what else do we have to
figure out in this meeting well I I did
write something about annotations
um yeah please share yeah please yeah
fine right right
so
this is
this is for the workflow of migrating
top level code to be compiled yep and
this is some some annotations and these
are things we talked about the other day
so I just wrote them down right right
fine so here is
this is
typed hint is a thing we considered
where
you know you you can put this into a
function but it evaluates away yeah the
compiler uses it but the evaluator you
know throws it away
okay I mean is this the right name do we
want this I I think we want this but I'm
not sure that I'm wondering about the
name but let's talk about its semantics
again for a second okay this is in the
source code
and in an unevaluated thing like a pure
function like this it would still be
there correct
so it's not a replacement for typed
yeah I mean type to something which has
its own separate existence and its own
separate calculus exactly yes well which
is that it doesn't have any top level
calculus and it doesn't and the fact
that it doesn't have it right exactly
does not must not evaluate
yeah okay
okay but so so
the point of this is that you put this
in code
and you're spraying this into code
in kind of the hopes
that well um go ahead I mean I just
think it's it's you know if we have some
nice mechanism I mean including the
stuff that no is just showing where it
says I mean okay the zero I think would
be something like what no is just
showing where you run it and it says oh
count for types of this function here
and it highlights it right and then you
go in your code and you write a type
tint or type hint you know around that
piece of code to help it
thank you
I think that the next fancier thing
would be if we had some I shouldn't even
bring this up but like if we had some
you know interface where as you're
writing it it's trying to run the type
inferencer and it's sort of highlighting
your code so before that's a great idea
that would be great yeah okay explain to
me when you use typed and when you use
type hint
we would use types as like the formal
arguments of variables okay like here
for example that's when you would use
typed
and so type hint
is merely used sort of in the body of
code to say by the way like an assert or
something by the way this is the type
this is supposed to have is that correct
I I think that's I think that's a
reasonable statement but right now we
use types right we we do use for that
but that stops things
restrict that to pipes to be only the
arguments of them no no I think you
could use types there
um absolutely you could use type that
it's just typed as an impediment to
writing a function that you can evaluate
you see
right so we wouldn't promote I think
type would still work in that role but
absolutely right but there were so many
functions in the compiler that don't
have native anything or compile anything
there's so many functions in the
compiler that don't don't evaluate away
I mean the goal is to run this function
in evaluated code and have it like
evaluate right right so you want
something that gets Stripped Away yes
that's that's so many array get data I
mean I mean one of the goal is to get
rid of that though I mean and but there
are hundreds of them I'm sorry what
hundreds up what are they
the things that we're using to develop
the language and and until we have the
the you know it's part of the
infrastructure of the code base and
there are a lot of things that we use at
the moment
we're not going to go on using them I
mean the whole point is to be able to
look our goal is very simple our goal is
to be able to have a workflow where
people normally just write in pure top
level code they try and compile it the
compiler cannot automatically figure out
types you add type hints so that the
compiler has a better chance of figuring
out the about about types and then it
compiles anything else and there are
still some compiler only constructs I
mean I think we've we've talked about
this I mean that there are things like
you know
pointers that really don't exist but but
there's no hope yeah okay so this is for
a specific workflow the workflow is okay
you wrote top level code you're trying
to Hint it so that top level code can be
sent through the compiler if you're
writing code that is purely you know
compilation first and never had a hope
of being top level code then it's
different story yes yes that's exactly
that's clear exactly yeah yeah so
the thing that I'm a little bit
I I think type
hint isn't good I think type hint is
more promising
yeah I I agree although it is a little
unfortunate with the
other types but yeah
well but it isn't in a sense because
typed says it really is this type
type hint is merely a hint well no no it
is saying it really is this type if it
isn't this type everything you know it's
going to fail
what what's saying that type interesting
type hint like type hint if you tell it
type hint I think this is a machine
integer and then it says and then the
type inferencer says I can guarantee
it's a machine real that will be an
error it's not just gonna be like oh the
hint was I'm going to ignore it it
cannot ignore it well fair enough but I
mean I think
we're delicately saying it's a hint even
though it really isn't a hint yeah
right I mean it's a hint in the sense
that it's not like you know you don't
have to specify it you don't you know in
many cases
what was that well I mean the main point
here is
how do we signal the fact that this is
if we are saying this is liked typed
except that it evaporates on evaluation
well I think we're not necessarily going
to say that so here's the thing right
with typed right now we right now
advertise two usages of typed one of
them is in basically the sort of the uh
declaration language so it's how you
it's how you refer to the arguments of
functions and it's how you refer to the
types of in function declarations and
stuff like that right and that's kind of
mostly outside of compiled code the
other usage of type that we advertise
typed that we advertise is for inside of
compiled code for telling it by the way
when I run two plus X their output of
that should be a packed array or
something like that right and so I think
the idea would be to stop advertising
that second usage is typed and and only
I mean it'll still work but we won't
advertise it but then type in will
replace that usage but type in would not
be used you know in in function
arguments and stuff like that because
evacuations correct yeah
well so so they would actually have
completely disjoint usages it's just
that type in will take over what
something a typed currently does
and the reason that we have a typed in
that second you know in the body type
Place well this is a bad example I I
don't care I don't care I don't care the
reason that we have typed inside the
body right now is what
I mean I can't always figure out the
types I mean there might be cases it
really is yeah yeah because it's
ambiguous it's an example Stephen you've
got an intermediate expression in the
body there that's not part of the type
signature so it's not one of the input
types and it's not the output type of
the type thing it's an intermediary type
with a short-term lifespan that you you
can't ascertain that you can't well okay
fine okay for some reason you can't
refer the type yeah maybe because the
functions are polymorphic in some way
yeah it might be a numeric array or pack
array new America real packed array you
don't know which of the two it is you
know the type and the rank but you don't
know which of the two but but is there a
deterministic thing that it is it's just
we don't know it or is that is it the
case often you have a choice array and
you have a choice between a pectoral
numeric array but you don't know regular
ones is so for example uh to take a
similar example to what Mark is saying
like let's say you run total of range of
n okay and N is a machine integer right
yep the question is what did range
return it could have returned to packed
array or it could have returned a list
vector or it could have returned a
numeric array or maybe something else
right and that's
you know
in that case it doesn't really matter it
could have returned to any of them it
probably won't affect the performance
that much probably pack to raise the
best choice but but it was legitimately
ambiguous and you might have to you
might decide to pick
which one you want okay but that really
is quite well named as type hint
that case
yeah yeah well that is the case
I wonder if it's more like a type cast
though and we need to cast anyway so we
need to make cast disappear not not
necessarily it's about function
selection as well you see like like like
creating a list you might there are
different sorts of lists you might want
to create
and this is a guide you know I mean I
like the fact that it has the word hint
in it because it suggests that you can
run it without no that's not going to
work it's not going to be fine okay
maybe type another date like an
annotation
well that sounds too formal I think
yeah well the only I I think it's not
bad I I would
I don't know particular for having a
short name because otherwise
we could use like we did we type
specifier this double colon
um
I mean both with parentheses it's an
interesting thought I mean I think
right I mean there was talk about how do
you know it was typed too of giving
typed special syntax but but I think
part of the problem is that I mean part
of the problem is just that it
introduces more API like hieroglyphics
no we but the other problem is next but
maybe we can reuse this syntax in some
ways I think it's it's difficult to uh
you know the scoping needs to be very
clear with the syntax because it's hard
you know you sometimes need to do typed
around the head of the expression
sometimes around the whole expression
correct Etc yes there are subtleties yes
foreign well I think we could start off
with just it being type hint yeah fine
okay so so we'll add that do it sounds
good right as a random point also is
that you you might imagine in the
category of having special syntax
maybe this is a bad idea you could
imagine having it so that you know in
the in the I don't know what to call it
the things that Noah are showing those
sort of snack Trace looking things you
might imagine showing the type hints in
some some special way where maybe it
doesn't even show the type hint itself
but it only shows you know it's colored
and it has an industry type it is
although that might cause all sorts of
problems because maybe the thing you
need to change is the type hint so yeah
yeah I don't know but well the question
of whether the tight pinch should show
up in a different color is an
interesting one and it's certainly its
type setting could involve
you know not wishing to reuse the word
type of type setting and type hint
because obviously those are slightly
disjoints yes but but having type hint
to be a different color seems
interesting to me like having it be gray
or something like that why don't we why
don't we color the types a different
color you see and do that in typed and
type hints
well the only thing is that uh well
types in general can just be strings
actually sorry I don't think my name
really does this but
uh it could just color whatever the
second argument of typed is yes that's
what I mean I mean yeah yeah I mean that
could could be some kind of light
well then it makes maybe although
sometimes I oh okay I guess if we think
of it as this is a way of telling you
this is a type hint that's fine but if
we think of this as this is the color we
want for types they're gonna be all
sorts of things like cast and so on
where the types are not going to be that
color and then it'll make you sad
yeah they're not always yeah maybe
you're let me take one of those things
where you learn that you know oh good
localized variables are green and then
and then you know there's some case
where actually yeah no you're you're
you're right yeah yeah no you're
absolutely right it's a bad idea right
you're completely right
well I'm not sure that the whole typed
thing shouldn't be a different color and
I think that should be investigated
because I think it maybe make code much
or or even what about the following
thing making everything
the the word typed and its type
specification a smaller font
oh that's scary
I mean I just think that I predict that
will look very strange but well okay I I
might not I think it might be that it
just you know depends on how encrusted
with type stuff
a typical thing is because this syntax
has helped quite a lot actually
um
foreign
when we actually have realistic code
okay if you have an example of some
realistic code Tom we could look at it
do you have a big chunk of realistic
code
um no okay all right let's not worry
about this right now let's look if
compiled right fine so this is I mean
pretty simple
and actually this would be and there is
a thing like this actually but it's
basically
you know if it's in evaluated mode
you execute this and if you're in
compiled mode you actually well yeah
right this seems fine to me I mean this
seems like a is that the good name
foreign you know it's interesting
because we've got similar kinds of
things
where we have a much less streamlined
version of it you know like like you
know we have variables that say wait a
minute we have things for the front end
right front end execute and we have
another one
the heck is it called well if something
that evaluates in the cloud
so we have that front-end backtick file
name we have like various functions that
evaluate in the front-end evaluator no
no no I'm saying no difference yeah
there's a there is a wrapper that means
well in most other environments you can
just have a variable that's like dollar
am I in the weird environment and then
you can just say if dollar I'm in the
weird environment than this otherwise
why but the problem is that doesn't work
with the compiler because it has to know
to not even try and compile the other
Branch yeah yeah yeah
this seems reasonable to me
right okay right
I'll I'll Implement these yeah
excellent
okay good stuff guys